montigny le bretonneux remporte dans la
douleur le derby contre maurepas mené 1
à 0 sur leur pelouse à la mi-temps
lésigny montain se sont arrachés en
seconde période pour égaliser marquer le
coup décisif dans les dernières minutes
de la partie par la sentinelle koyka
karamoko score final 2 buts à 1 mon but
je me dis ah c'est la bonne faux pas je
rate gît dans le but
alors heureusement que je rate pas aussi
mais bon voilà on essaie de faire les
choses pour le bien de l'équipe
on se concentre et on sait ce qu'il faut
faire
cette performance a permis de briser une
série noire de trois ans sans victoire
de montigny le bretonneux contre
maurepas pour réaliser cet exploit le
staff de l'équipe avaient étudié son
adversaire du jour et avait mis en place
un plan de jeu on a décidé de pas pressé
très haut
parce qu'on sait qu'ils aiment bien
repartir d'assez bas nous aspirer donc
on avait décrété de descendre de n'est
pas sept blocs pardon du un peu plus bas
pour pouvoir les contrer et puis à
m'apprendre a manqué un petit peu de
justesse toute la première mi temps en
deuxième c'est un petit peu mieux qu'ils
ont baissé le pied au classement
montigny le bretonneux remonte à la 8e
place et comptent désormais quatre
points d'avancé sur la zone de
relégation
on sait qu'il reste encore deux places
pour pour descendre c'était que nous on
vient de monter donc on veut arriver qu
militer dans la division l'objectif
c'est le maintien on va essayer de se
maintenir plus rapidement possible
tous les matches sont durs à jouer vont
jouer tous les matchs sont joués à 200%
moi c'est comme ça que je vois les
choses les choses
prochain match pour montigny le
bretonneux le dimanche 30 avril à
domicile contre les mureaux une équipe
qui lutte également pour sa survie en
excellence